it's beautiful it's sunshiny it's easter
it is adrian hauser on the mound here's
buxton one on one out
and now down the line to the pool side
into the corner
polanco rounding second buxton pulls
into second with a double
and the twins have a couple of hits
early on down that left field line
against adrian hauser
kepler with three hits on opening day
thursday
a chance to drive in some runs here in
the first inning
no dribbler left side a runway score
kepler retired he just on a check swing
put it on the ground to the left side it
didn't leak through for a hit but the
twins take the first lead yeah you'll
take it any way you can get it and
get the run in and kepler does the job
jake cave will lead things off for
minnesota here in the second and it's
two and two cave
takes a call strike three down he goes
anderleton simmons with one out he likes
that first pitch brewer set up to turn a
double play and there's a ground ball
arcia wong
hiro with the pitch
around the horn they go five four three
double play
good play by arcia the throw by wong
kind of you know handcuffing here a
tough pick able to handle it well keep
his foot on the bag bottom of the second
bradley junior reaches here is luis
arias now
uria is only
24 years of
age hard down the line
and cage gonna cut it off bradley jr
into third urias with a stand-up double
a slider that stayed up one of the few
that he's honed
and uria is able to keep it fair down
the line
so the e4 and now a double and the
brewers are in position to tie it up
second and third with one out for manny
pina
here's a 1-2 pina in the air center
field that's going to do it deep enough
for
a run to score jbj will tag throw comes
to third and the brewers tied up on a
set of fly by manny pena just like that
so the air does come back to
haunt minnesota pinch hitter too for
byron buxton
byron buxton was removed from the game
a non-coven related illness
brent rooker
is going to hit for byron buxton one two
runner goes penis thrown a second right
on the bag the tag in time
and he paid you with a rifle the second
right on the money quick release wow
we're all tied at one as we go to the
fifth cave is in there
quiet on the base pads a swing at a miss
hauser with a strikeout of jake cave
second time he's got the lefty that's
number four
for adrian hauser talking up on mitch
garbert swinging in a
drive into right and into the corner and
it is going to go
mitch garver's first hit of the year
goes to the opposite field and the twins
retake the lead well good at bat he
walked his previous time up and now this
time he goes oppo and hit it just far
enough michael
pineda is going to be the batteries
there he is
bouncing ball going to second look at
that flip one but first oh what a double
play
how about that
oh man
[Applause]
to hear a spectacular double play
is down by one here in the fifth inning
with only one out and two on and here is
kissing hiram
penina all set again
here he comes hiro struck out swinging
down and away with a
slider big strikeout
for pineda
and with two outs rocco baldelli will
leave pineda in to face christian yelich
[Music]
bouncing ball the shift was on
no chance of it out here would be an
infield hit for yellidge
shift actually heard of that time
yelich reaches on an infield hit that
loads the bases with two outs
but now they're loaded up for their
cleanup battery
high fastball got him
and pineda leaves them full
new sign and ready the pitch
swinging in a
and
safe at second base a high throw from
hira
who had some throwing issues as a second
baseman
safe at second base a high throw from
hira and his toss to uranus put him into
the air and
arize was able to just barely sneak in
under the tag brings up max kepler they
got first base open
and kepler the left field down for a hit
arise scoring and polanco coming in
behind him and max kepler picks a great
time for his fourth hit
real nice piece of hitting right here
got himself a little breaking ball up
out over the plate and didn't try and do
too much just real simple approach
three balls on the strike
down the right field line hit well and
gone
hits a frozen rope out of here
two-run home run and the twins have
opened it up here in the sixth inning
[Applause]
six to one minnesota cino hits his first
of the year it's now 6-1 twins
that's hit hard in the center field this
is way back and it is up and it is gone
a home run
for jackie bradley jr
the first home run of the year for the
brewers
comes from jbj bat
and simmons with a drive to the gap in
left center field and it'll go all the
way to the wall
cave to third being waved around and he
will score
andrews and simmons now trying for third
base
and he's out
he's adamant that he got in there by
the swim slide
this i mean you you want to reward
a player for
being able to do that
now the pitch hit in the air and deep
into left sutter and at the warning
track and gonna be caught
but a run's gonna score
nelson cruz delivers on a long sac fly
the brewers are down to their last
strike travis shaw and the 2-2 swung on
and missed and that is the ball game
eight to two the twins win it they win
the series